elle est spécialisée dans l'industrie de
précision l'entreprise mécanique
ateliers de coignières fabrique des
pièces à partir de machines à commande
numérique
elle réalise plus de 80% de son activité
dans l'aéronautique impacté par la crise
sanitaire cette pme de 26 salariés à
décrocher une aide de la région
ile-de-france 450000 euros pour son
projet d'investissement
cette aide va nous permettre de
continuer à moderniser notre outil de
production à robotiser robotisée et
digitalisées numériser toutes les
informations qu'on peut avoir
aujourd'hui et en suivi de production
le but est de continuer la
diversification sur la partie clientèle
qu'on avait où on a une clientèle qui
était très accro nautique et qui
malheureusement a été fortement impacté
avec la baisse du trafic aérien
et aujourd'hui on va essayer de se
reconvertir sur le secteur ferroviaire
ou ou militaires ou peut-être automobile
du côté de guyancourt la société gamme
et cas fabrique des pièces pour des
prototypes de l'industrie automobile et
pétrolières face à la crise et une
baisse d'activité entre 20 et 30%
cette entreprise a mis en place un prêt
garanti par l'état et reporter les
charges sociales et fiscales pour se
relancer elle souhaite investir 800
mille euros sur trois ans dont 350 mille
euros de subventions obtenues auprès du
conseil régional
alors notre axe c'est surtout de
développer tout ce qui est digital
puisqu'aujourd'hui on reçoit des plans
en 3d numérisés on les envoie sur nos
machines
donc on a encore des machines numériques
à acquérir on va essayer d'aller
chercher des marchés surtout ce que
l'hydrogène par rapport à tout ce qui
est moteur électrique également essayé
de se redéployer sur tout ce qui est
médicale
spatiale est également tous cas défense
au total dans le département des
yvelines 16 entreprises ont été
sélectionnées pour obtenir une
subvention de la région des projets
allant de la relocalisation d'activités
à la modernisation d'outils de
production une enveloppe globale de 10
millions 250 mille euros